des serveurs qui ne chôment pas des
terrasses remplier de sortie voilà une
image que vous ne verrez pas demain à
dix journées en côte d'or
car comme l'imposent la loi le 1er mai
est fériée et chômée
sauf nécessité au continuité de service
une décision qui fait bondir les
restaurateurs contraints de fermer leurs
portes ce mercredi pour moi c'est la
première fois ça peut être plus de 30
ans que je fais ce métier nous sommes
navrés
nous sommes dans une dans une ville
gastronomie touristique eux
où j'ai mes 45 collaborateurs qui
demandent qu'à travailler
on nous force à fermer deux personnes
vont mettre les us et usage de notre
profession en ballottage en les aidant
non ça va pas et si en plus de ça
c'était la france entière mais c'est
uniquement la côte d'or
car si la loi existe elle a été
appliquée uniquement dans le département
l'an passé 11 restaurateurs avaient
ainsi été contrôlées et des infractions
relevées comme ici à l'oiseau des ducs
ou encore dans ces bars de la place de
la mairie on se fait contrôler l'année
dernière par deux inspectrices nous et
puis bien d'autres
comme quoi effectivement on était une
interdiction totale de travailler avec
une possibilité d'une amende de 750
euros par salarié à l'envoyer sur deux
établissements ça fait quinze mille
euros
l'inspection du travail a rappelé lundi
dans un communiqué que la loi s'applique
est toujours et que les établissements
devaient donc fermé le syndicat des
restaurateurs au chiffre d'affaires en
baisse après 23 samedi de manifestations
demandent que cela évolue
la loi effectivement doit être changé je
pense que l'action que nous voulons
c'est à dire la fermeture totalité des
restaurants comme nous sommes obligés de
le faire va permettre peut-être de faire
réagir de faire modifier cette loi qui
qui est pour nous un punk est il faut
bien le reconnaître
par solidarité les hôtels qui disposent
d'un restaurant les fermerons demain
midi enfin malgré l'interdiction
certains restaurateurs devraient quand
même essayé de mettre le couvert